It turns out you can do one half of the job in one hour's time. We can get one
half by drawing a diagram to help us out. We know that it takes two hours for
us to do the entire assignment. So, if two hours passes, then we've finished
our complete assignment; both of these bars would be full. So, what we can do
is we can take our entire two hours and split it up into one hour increments.
Each of these would represent one hour. And each of these on the corresponding
side would represent the amount of work for the fraction being done in that
hour. So if we split our time in half we could split our assignment in half.
We'll know that we'll finish half the assignment in one hour. And then the
other half in the next hour. So this is how we know that in one hour we only
finish half of the assignment. Great work if you got that fraction.